nick foles and company driving down the
field against the nfl's best defense on
their own home turf nick foles finds a
way to get it done with 56 seconds left
the touchdown pass to golden tate they
missed the two-point conversion the
score was 16-15 tarik cohen with the
35-yard
return
mitch trubisky throwing the pass to alan
robinson to get the bears into field
goal position and then it came down to a
43-yard attempt by cody parkey it
apparently got tipped although if it got
tipped it did not get tipped by much it
was a very minor adjustment to the
flight of the ball but it was enough to
send it careening into the upright it
fell down and hit the crossbar it could
have gone either way and it landed in
the end zone and chris sims my brain
would not process it i kept expecting
tony guarente to come on and tell me
something else had happened than what i
saw or that something else had occurred
there was some sort of a second chance
that cody parker was gonna get that that
was not gonna be the outcome eagles 16
bears 15 but that was the outcome bears
go home eagles advance uh it was and it
was watching it live when it first hit
the left upright
and went down i thought it was going
through you know and i didn't you know
you really couldn't tell on tv whether
it bounced forward or backwards at first
so i had thought it was bouncing
backwards until of course you realize it
hit the goal line or whatever after
after bouncing off the crossbar but
that's a great point i thought when i
saw it hit the the the crossbar it was
going over i did i was stunned when it
landed in the end exactly right i saw it
and i'm sitting there going oh my god i
yelled out at my house i said oh my god
he made it i couldn't believe it and
then i was like oh no i'm wrong
but regardless i found the game style
refreshing okay this is why i like uh
playoff low scoring football you could
see the not only the intensity through
both teams but you could feel the
pressure on the field because it was a
10-9 game and it was you know it was so
close throughout that every decision
that was made by the coaches and the
quarterbacks you knew was going to
affect
the overall game where you know
sometimes you get in shootouts and it's
just back and forth back and forth but
regardless the story of the philadelphia
eagles and nick foles coming through
again uh i sit here in amazement talking
about it i mean it goes to what i said
at the opening you just you couldn't
write this stuff and then added to that
okay the guy we were worried about on
chicago all year cody parker okay he
comes back to bite him in the butt the
other guy they worried about in chicago
mitchell trubisky played phenomenal
football and if you told me the chicago
bears defense had a 15 to 10 lead with
five minutes left to go in the fourth
quarter i would have said well the bears
are going the divisional playoff round
and the the unit that brought them there
did not get it done in the biggest
moment of the year and now the eagles
move on
and by the way i've worried about you
all year too actually for two seasons
now it's parky not parker oh yeah i say
it did i do it again did i say it i've
said it three times
i'll say it maybe six times to match the
number of double doinks he's had this
year
it's very important that on days like
this we get the goat's name right it's
cody parker and tony's credit after the
game after the game cody parkey owned
the miss here he is speaking to
reporters
you can't make this up i mean i feel
terrible with the team down
that's on me so i have to own it i have
to be a man and you know it's
unfortunately uh
unfortunately that's the way it went
today
i mean a lot of people are giving him
credit for you know facing the music i
don't know what other alternative he had
it's not like he was going to escape i
mean you you it's you know i i mean
every once in a while a star player
finds a way to sneak out of the locker
room that guy wasn't getting out of that
locker room and and it's good he turned
he faced it and yes and i mean what can
you do and i don't think he realized in
that moment the ball was tipped i don't
know that makes it any better right but
if the ball's tipped it's a little
easier to understand why why it didn't
go through but uh upright crossbar lands
in the end zone and the chicago bears
season is over after a 12-4 magical ride
and let me tell you chris yeah people in
chicago were so caught up in this team
it was 1985 all over again they just
presumed the bears are going to punch
their ticket against the eagles and we
said it last week be careful what you
wish for right they had a chance to kind
of lay down let the vikings come to town
i think they would have made quick work
of the vikings yesterday they let the
defending champs with the horseshoe
stuck in place horseshoes don't
ordinarily go right come to town and and
oh yeah we're fine you're not fine and
i'm telling you people i talked to in
chicago ah yeah that's not i do i do two
spots every week on on uh 670 the score
in chicago and i was on there friday and
i made my case for why i thought the
eagles were gonna win and when i was
done they didn't have anything to say
they just moved on to the next topic
like yeah okay all right fine idiot yeah
it's like okay all right but we've seen
this movie enough times with nick falls
that we know it's viable that even if
the bears were going to win that game it
wasn't going to be just show up and win
you're going to have to fight and
scratch and claw because the eagles are
not going to lay down for anybody yeah
no they're not and they match up with
anybody and they fix some of the issues
that we saw them have problems with you
know midway through the year and or even
later into the year right around when
carson wentz got hurt you know nick
foles has been phenomenal we know that
he's also been the beneficiary of you
know taking over the team when the
defensive line finally got 100 healthy
the offensive line got 100 healthy uh
but the eagles are dangerous and this is
the team i think we thought we would all
see all year long i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell you the truth i mean i didn't
really still buy in until i saw
yesterday i really didn't i thought okay
they got a little magic going i know
they're dangerous but they played three
teams the last three games of the year
they kind of matched up well with uh but
no i'm a believer now they are dangerous
this is a different football team and
i'll go back to something like tony
dungy has said the last two weeks mike
that nick foles has kind of forced them
to play back to their strengths as a
football team and they do run the ball
they use the short passing game as an
extension of their run game he's been
phenomenal at throwing the ball under
pressure uh and the eagles defense and
young secondary with the with with it
being banged up has been phenomenal here
the last few weeks they they've really i
got to give the coaches of the
philadelphia eagles a ton of respect
because they have fixed so many of the
issues they had on their team
schematically in a very short time and
got this team turned around and believe
in and thinking they're going to go back
on another super bowl run
we had the conversation several weeks
ago after the eagles beat the rams and
we started to recognize that maybe
there's something special about the
eagles with nick foles on the field you
had the assessment and i believe this is
accurate that carson wentz is the better
quarterback but the eagles are the
better team when folz plays because they
don't get fascinated by
and infatuated with and smitten by
everything once can do and deviate from
their game plan like they do often with
wentz they can just continue to go about
their business with foals and it makes
them a better team and i think that's
the key and and we're creeping closer
and closer right to that moment where
it's time to have the conversation about
the future and the moment is not here
yet but a week from now it may be
because 48 to 7 was the score when
carson wentz took the eagles down to new
orleans i know if nick foles takes the
eagles there and the spread right now is
none if they even just cover they don't
have to win if they keep it within nine
or closer
that's when you have to say you know
what yeah i know we gave up everything
to move up to two back in 2016. i know
that carson wentz is the guy that we
assume is going to be our franchise guy
for the next decade but
we got to do what's in the best interest
of the team and what's in the best
interest of the team is getting what you
can for wentz and making falls the
long-term answer for as long as he can
play he's still in a position where he's
got six seven eight good years left
minimum that with the way quarterbacks
are playing into the late 30s right
let's just ride with falls and get what
we can for wentz recognizing that wence
and they went nuts in philly when i said
this earlier this year on wip
wentz
is damaged goods and he's more damaged
now than he was back in september
because he got the back thing now that
they have to worry about yeah they're
they they are they're coming down to the
the last hour here of going to be a very
interesting conversation yeah whether
you're right they keep it close this
week if they somehow find a way to win
they're going to have to have some
interesting decisions in the
philadelphia you know uh
front office about what they want to do
uh going forward because i do think
you're gonna see a a backlash or a
calling from the philadelphia fans to go
no we we want nick foles we believe in
him it's it's really going to be
fascinating to see and getting back to
the point you know you were saying and
kind of giving me credit for that the
the team plays different with nick foles
at quarterback than carson wentz yeah
the one thing and i think you've heard
me say this the one thing that i think
has changed about the philadelphia
eagles is they're not afraid of third
and two and when i say that when i say
they're not afraid of third and two and
third and three they're very being very
patient with their game plan calling and
they're getting their play calling run
up the middle okay it's second and seven
let's throw a screen to receiver okay
it's third and three now when they get
you in third and three that's new
england patriots type of stuff and then
you go man it's third and three they
could run the ball they could throw a
screen they could throw the ball deep
they could do a little pick route so
they are they have understood what suits
them best and what positions they feel
the most comfortable in and we've seen
since nick foles has taken over they're
unbelievable on third down and i think a
lot of that is because of the way doug
peterson's calling the football game and
matching it up with nick fole's style of
play
overall for the day falls wasn't
spectacular 25 or 40 266 yards two
touchdowns two picks 77.7 passer rating
but on that final drive 12 plays 60
yards six of nine for 59 yards the
touchdown to golden tate on fourth and
goal and that was such a great sequence
of plays first and goal and they run the
ball all right we got three more chances
second and goal they run the ball oh
they got two more chances after that
third down play it's like oh here we go
and there it was the first read the
golden tate he spoke to peter king after
the game you can look at football
morning in america at
profootballtalk.com for all of golden
tate's comments about how how gratifying
it was for him to have the the season
put in his hands he got open against
shurik mcmanus caught the pass and the
eagles win although they still had to
sweat out and stats raises a good
question if cody parkey makes that kick
right
what do the eagles do at quarterback is
that the fact that that the sh the
season got derailed for something
unrelated to nick foles play
are we right now saying okay look they
got this far but carson wentz is the guy
going i do think that would have ended
the conversation out of the fact that
you know really the eagles had a chance
at one point to control the game and
foal's two interceptions kind of hurt
them in those moments i mean there was
the one interception where they were
kind of on
you know feel gold fringe maybe infield
gold territory if i remember exactly
right and then of course the scrambling
or the throw into the back of the end
zone when they were definitely in field
goal range looked like somebody might
have hit his arm as he threw it and he
throws an interception into the end zone
yeah i think that would have probably
ended all of these discussions and the
philadelphia fan base would have just
got okay up the magic's over and wentz
is our guy and i think we would see that
foles had a has a big market
in free agency or wherever he ends up
after the season but now that's changed
and now it's let's see another week and
evaluate this team and see what he does
and i just wanted to say one more thing
one of the cool things mike about that
that fourth down touchdown play you know
that's a like a staple
west coast play that's the play like
sprint right option that we've seen joe
montana roll out and throw the ball in
the back of the end zone to dwight clark
right same type of play but what they
did was they did it with three receivers
and i bet just because of the three
receivers it's usually two receivers
that was just enough nuance to throw vic
fangio off and the defense and how they
set up and i just don't think they were
expecting that concept and again just
shows the genius of doug peterson again
and these little moments with these got
to have it plays he finds the correct
formations and matchups
constantly he is one of the clutches
coaches i have ever seen in these
moments and there is something to that
and that's why the eagles are who they
are right now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports